today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
alright everybody this is this is really
it we're down to the last days of this
2020 presidential
and senate and house election and
everything that we have been predicting
about the way this election is going to
go down is coming true
the voter suppression the use of the
courts and lawsuits by donald trump to
stop the counting of votes he's saying
he's going to do it
the encouraging of violence which i am
going to get to shortly and now
a leak to axios that donald trump's plan
if it is even remotely plausible
that he might win on election night he
is planning to declare victory
this is not a rehearsal these are the
last 36 hours and they are doing it and
democracy is at stake here
it is not time to be hyperbolic which is
why i am telling it to you like it is
democracy is
at stake here and this is of course
exactly
as we have been predicting for months
even though we never have final results
on election day
typically there is enough information on
election day
to make a call about the winner donald
trump's plan
if it's close if it's tight will be
to declare that he has won which will
weaponize his supporters
in the event the numbers start turning
against him
as the mail-in ballots are all counted
and he will put pressure on the courts
to have to take it from him by saying on
election night
i won i'm the winner this is from an
axios report
which uh reports that quote president
trump has told confidants
he will declare victory on tuesday night
if it looks like he's ahead
according to three sources familiar with
his private comments
trump will declare victory even if the
electoral or electoral college outcome
will still depend
on uncounted votes in key states like
pennsylvania
trump has a plan which he has talked
about with aids
to get up in front of a podium somewhere
it looked like it was going to be
at one of his hotels now it looks like
it will be at the white house itself
and declare that he has won now this is
not
a no matter what scenario if trump gets
totally blown out early
he's not going to do this in fact he'll
do the opposite which is if biden looks
like he's way ahead
trump will say the numbers don't look
right and we have to wait
until all the votes come in but in any
scenario other than a biden blowout
in which he leads or wins some
combination
of ohio florida north carolina texas
iowa arizona georgia pennsylvania
he will be saying i won we have been
re-elected now
trump's team is preparing to make this
claim more specific by alleging
that mail-in ballots counted after
november 3rd
shouldn't be allowed that those ballots
would be evidence of election fraud how
can people vote after november 3rd
it's not true but they're going to say
it and prognosticators say
that it is very plausible that on
election night
trump might be slightly ahead in for
example pennsylvania
there are many scenarios in which trump
needs pennsylvania to win
the entire election could hinge on
pennsylvania
and pennsylvania is seeing five plus day
delays for normal mail
to be sent back and forth pennsylvania
is the
the site of a lot of uh preemptive legal
wrangling
so you could have a situation where
trump claiming victory in pennsylvania
implies that he got 270 electoral votes
but he could end up losing pennsylvania
if and when all
of the properly legally cast ballots are
counted the axios report goes on to say
that donald trump's team
is baselessly planning to claim
that democrats have stolen the election
if the results
flip from trump to biden as mail-in
ballots are counted
and axio says that this is the first
time trump has actually explicitly
discussed
these intentions for tuesday night he's
been alluding to it for a while but now
he's actually saying it now i i must
remind
everybody so we're on the same page
listen very carefully here we have never
had full final results on election day
no state ever reports final
certified results on election night no
state
is expected to the news organizations
will start to make projections
based on ballots outstanding state
demographics exit polls
and more to make calls about who likely
has won
typically they can do this relatively
accurately because we know there aren't
that many outstanding ballots because
most people are voting in person you can
get
to a point where you know north carolina
biden's up 55-45 in a normal election
55-45
with 20 to go and in order to
take back that lead trump would need
percent of the remaining twenty percent
of belt not going to happen
you make a call north carolina goes for
biden this is going to be different
because there are so many people voting
by mail
reports of mail delays etc etc but the
results are never final on election
night it's actually even crazier trump
is saying we need all of the results on
november 3rd
when the polls close in hawaii it will
already be november 4th on the east
coast what trump wants
is impossible unless you want to make
some metaphysical argument about time
moving backwards or something like that
so the difference this year is not the
timing of the final results
the difference is when news
organizations will have enough
information
to make accurate projections he's going
to try to steal it
he's going to declare victory on tuesday
in every scenario other than a massive
blowout by joe biden
so we must all be ready for that and we
must be ready for the opposite scenario
where if trump is down
hugely at midnight he may reverse course
and say there's no way these numbers are
right based on our internal polling
we are not conceding anything which is
of course just a formality even if
biden has a blowout trump will say well
now we have to wait
but hopefully at that point it will be
too late the strategy is
cheat lawyers discounting ballots
claiming victory biden's lawyers had
better be ready
for some long nights because democracy
is depending on it
the future of our public health and
economy also depends on it let's talk
about that
the economy is collapsing and
coronavirus is exploding
and the next three months could be a
disaster
we have now seen the dow jones
industrial average drop more than
eight percent in the last couple of
weeks we have seen
even after the supposed record-setting
delightful fantastic
gdp numbers of the third quarter we
still are down more than eight points
annualized
from where we were gdp wise before the
pandemic
we are only getting into what is
predicted to be the worst period
in the united states from a public
health standpoint in literally a hundred
years
dr anthony fauci said six months ago if
we don't get this under control
we are talking about a hundred thousand
cases per day come fall
and trump has said no way and
republicans said no way
and trump said fouchy doesn't always
know what he's talking about and yet
friday we saw for the first time ever
100 000 cases in a single day
more than 101 000 in fact but what's a
thousand cases between
friends at this point but but but the
deaths aren't going to climb they said
well
takes three or more weeks to see the
death numbers climb but they already are
as we've seen the seven seven-day moving
average of deaths bottom out around
october 17th
and start to trickle up up up and likely
to continue
and this is not because we're doing more
testing this is what trump is claiming
we're finding more cases because we've
upped testing
testing is up 7 in the last week
cases are up 19 percent testing is up
7 in the last week hospitalizations are
up
13 it is not testing in the month of
october
only georgia and hawaii saw decreases in
hospitalization california was steady
every other state saw increases in
hospitalization
we have an administration that has no
plan to deal with the virus
but also doesn't even understand that if
their focus is the economy
you have to deal with the virus if
deaths double
to where we're seeing 2 000 2500 deaths
per day for one month two months three
months
things are going to have to shut down
businesses are going to have to shutter
that will be a disaster for the economy
now
trump may be a lame duck president by
then
if he loses tomorrow or he may be
re-elected president
and rewarded with four more years
despite having no plan and
listen if he can get reelected with no
plan
you can bet your ass that he's not going
to then come up with a plan
he'll have been re-elected he will see
it as a referendum that went his way
on his handling of coronavirus so the
economy rides on tomorrow's election
the handling of the virus and america's
public health
rides on the handling of the election
trade policy
international alliances the perception
of the united states as a sane and
sensible country
it's all riding on tomorrow's election
i'll be streaming results
live starting at 7 00 pm eastern
tomorrow
tuesday on youtube twitch and facebook
i hope you will join me let me know how
your vote went
on twitter where you can find me at
deepakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware
of for so long and other things got in
the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the david pakman show
primarily depends on
folks like you grabbing a membership at
joinpackman.com
coupon code good only until tomorrow
election day
2020 now saves you 66
2020 now at joinedpakman.com
if you were wondering whether donald
trump would encourage violence
after the election you don't have to
wait until after the election
because donald trump is already
encouraging and praising violence done
by his supporters over the weekend in
texas
a group of truck driving flag waving
trump supporters
surrounded a joe biden campaign bus joe
biden was not on this bus at the time
and there was even a sideswipe incident
where one is the
one of these trump trucks sideswiped a
vehicle
that was following the bus driven by
biden campaign staff this is a hit and
run i mean this this is violence this is
an attack
and it led to the biden campaign
actually cancelling events in texas
because of security concerns now of
course anybody in favor of law and order
would denounce this right not so far in
fact they've been praising it
donald trump tweeted video of the
incident
with the message i love texas during one
of his
dozen corona rallies over the weekend
said doing this to the biden bus
was a hot thing take a look did anybody
see the picture of their crazy bus
driving down the highway they're
surrounded by
like hundreds of cars and they're all
trump flags all over the place
what a group no
it's it's like a hot it's like a hot
thing see that's really
number one trending you know they won't
put that that's number one training
they come up with number one trending
it's uh
it's not a trend it's whatever they want
to do this
is really playing with fire his
gun-toting flag-waving supporters are
just waiting there what was the term
standing by so to speak to go absolutely
insane with the violence on trump say so
and here is donald trump saying this is
hot then trump at one of his rallies
this was last night in
opa-locka florida or apaloka
i'm not sure how it's pronounced
glorifying it and
bringing up antifa they had the thing
with these
really i'd say very good people they
were riding along the highway
and you had sleepy joe's bus
so they escorted the bus and the radical
left said oh what a horrible thing that
is to escort the bus
they don't tell you about antifa that go
around burning down your cities democrat
run only democrat wrong
they don't talk about that bopping
people over the head killing people
fox news of course typically all about
law abiding
celebrating it dismissing it here is
that lunatic fox news judge jeanine
pirro
saying this was americans taking the
election
into their own hands with vehicular
crimes
this was during an interview with newt
gingrich country right now
fascinating experience they're these
spontaneous
parades and boat parades and organized
get-togethers
not done by the campaign just people who
are so
energized they got to do something so
they're out there doing it every single
day
well it is it is stunning and uh what's
what's even
more stunning is what was just trending
and that is there's a biden
bust and it's surrounded by pickup
trucks uh on a highway all with trump
signs i mean it is
ordinary americans just taking this
election
uh into their own hands and and getting
out there and
being real clear on what they stand for
what is it they stand for because it
seems to me they stand for
violence vehicular crimes not counting
votes but stealing them
intimidating people at polling places
that's what i see them standing for
based on their actions
this is a call to violence and i
consider that attack on the highway
violence
messing around on highways is no joke it
puts lives
at risk this is violence and we have to
remember
what we are voting against here what we
have to stop here it's an emergency
but both sides do this right i mean back
in 2012
obama supporters were driving around in
convoys with guns and obama flags
violently attacking people sideswiping
vehicles showing up armed
oh hold on a second wait what that
didn't happen no
that didn't happen and if it did happen
we would know
because it would be 24 7 on fox news and
rush limbaugh
and all over the place and here instead
of denouncing it
the fox hosts and trump himself are
praising it
and i hate to do this but we have to go
back to it
and whatever you know after the results
after we have the results wednesday
tuesday
wednesday thursday friday i'm going to
come back to this
40 percent of voters at least think that
this authoritarian wannabe dictator is
doing a good enough job to get himself
re-elected
this is political terrorism and 40 of
the country is either
praising it or saying it's not bad
enough
that they're going to retract their vote
for donald trump
that says something really embarrassing
and disturbing
and disgusting and alarming about the
state
of culture and education in the united
states
i know that in the last 24 hours before
the election
the number one thing is not how the hell
do we fix
education and culture in this country so
that someone like trump could never do
what he has been able to do it's a
bigger question than for the last 24
hours
but it's disturbing to think about and
it's something we will have to deal with
regardless of the results of tomorrow's
election and i will go back to it
i will not be covering all of donald
trump's rallies from this weekend he did
i think four on friday four or five
saturday 5
yesterday more today the individual
rallies really don't matter what matters
is that these rallies are responsible
for at least 700 coronavirus deaths
based on a new stanford study
which i will get to later in the program
and the rallies are really
at the end stage of humiliating
authoritarian desperation and that's
where we will focus
because this is it guys we either end
this tomorrow or we get four more years
of it
there are rumors that trump might
continue doing rallies later in the week
if the election results are not yet
completely counted if you can imagine
but we are potentially getting to the
end of this but donald trump said
yesterday at a rally
that uh he's looking at firing anthony
fauci after the election he essentially
said
give me until after the election to do
it a fire fouchy chant
developed at trump's rally in appalachia
florida and trump said let me wait a
little
until after the election take a look
rounding the two i say
it drives them crazy it's rounding the
turn
because all they want to do you turn in
the news kovit kovet kovetkovico
would like to talk about covered and
then next year
here's what happens november 4th you
won't hear too much about it
you won't hear too much about it
[Applause]
don't tell anybody but let me wait till
a little bit after the election
i appreciate the advice this is a
sick country my friends this is a
disgusting and sick country we are
dealing with
30 40 of it anyway from day one
dismissing and ignoring and creating
conspiracy theories about the virus
anything to defend and justify trump's
terrible handling of the pandemic
making the top infectious disease doctor
enemy number one
to the point where he and his family his
daughters need
full-time security and now
demands for that doctor to be fired and
the president instead of saying no no no
this is a medical expert 40-year career
of fighting aids and other infectious
disease
trump says thanks for the advice i'm
gonna wait a little until after the
election
to fire fouchy and to be totally honest
you could put almost everything else
trump has done
the hundreds of scandals the tens of
thousands of law
like put it all aside this alone
when we have cases exploding for a third
time
twenty percent of the deaths despite
having only four percent of the
population
and trump says fire fouchy this
alone would be enough to say we must
remove donald trump
and by the way even if he loses he might
fire fouchy
during the interim lame duck period joe
biden would have to rehire him and i'm
sure that he would
94 million people have already voted
we will know soon it's hours now 36
48 72 maybe 96 hours and we will know
whether this man gets rewarded for
another four years imagine
saying i'll fire fauci after the
election
and getting re-elected that is what
could happen
let's now talk a little bit more about
what happened over the weekend
at these whacked-out rallies so donald
trump did more than a dozen rallies over
the last few days he's going crazy going
11 a.m to 11 p.m doing rallies in the
dark and the cold and the heat in the
wind complaining about all of the
weather at every single one of these
we've learned that these rallies are not
without negative effect we've seen
old folks get hypothermic after being
left at the rallies with no buses to
take them back to their cars
we've seen folks get heat stroked as
they start just spraying water onto
crowds in the extreme heat and sun
stanford study which i will talk about
has found that at least 700 people have
died of coronavirus
thanks to donald trump's rallies and it
is all about feeding his ego
if you are delusional or whacked enough
to even go to one of these rallies
during a pandemic
you're voting for trump he's not
convincing anybody
he's feeding his ego and just some of
the most insane things from the last
couple of days here i can't cover it all
it wouldn't be healthy to expose you to
all of it but
i'm going to play a few clips for you
from the different rallies trump here
actually saying out loud what his
philosophy has been which is
whatever obama did i will do the
opposite
frankly we just said what did obama do
and i heard and you know what i did i
did the opposite
i said what did obama do
and then i did the opposite then it
worked
now there's one thing that's missing
there which is everything obama did he
will undo
unless it's something he wants credit
for in which case trump will just claim
he did it
obama protected pre-existing conditions
with obamacare oh
i protected pre-existing conditions or i
will
what obama did veterans choice we did
veterans choice
just say i did it that's the piece that
was missing there
trump then continuing to glorify mob
violence
the surrounding of a joe biden bus and
the sideswiping of a staff
vehicle trump loves it they had the
thing with
these really i'd say very good people
they were riding along the highway and
you had sleepy joe's bus
so they escorted the bus and the radical
left said oh what a horrible thing that
is to escort the bus
they don't tell you about antifa that go
around burning down your cities democrat
run only democrat wrong
they don't talk about that bopping
people over the head killing people
extremely dangerous and we did an entire
segment on that so i won't
rehash it here uh then donald trump now
at a different rally donald trump says
you know if biden wins we're not going
to have anything
biden's going to he's been saying biden
will take away
electricity and indoor heating and
cooling
now he has another list of things joe
biden will take away
the biden lockdown will mean no school
no graduation no weddings
no thanksgiving no christmas no easter
no fourth of july
no future for american youth other than
that he's doing quite a good job right
the reality is all of those things have
happened
under trump due to his mishandling of
coronavirus
remember guys in march when trump said
let's do two weeks
two weeks of washing hands and then
we're gonna reopen on easter it's gonna
be amazing
it's trump's mishandling that led to
this it's a level of projection that
in this uh this close to the end of the
campaign
is just beyond words it's an
authoritarian nightmare as well
donald trump during one of his corona
rallies over the weekend
not accepting that there will be a
peaceful transition of power if he loses
and now they say will you respect the
decision of the voters
and will there be a friendly transition
first of all there's not going to be a
transition we're winning
but then you say then you say well
let me ask you four years ago was there
a friendly transition
they were spying on my campaign before i
even won
and what was worse was they were spying
on my campaign
after i won to overthrow the president
of the united states okay
which is called treason which is called
treason
and let's see what the hell happens i
don't know why it takes so long but it
takes a long time
trump still will not say there will be a
transition
we now know thanks to the report from
axios at the top of the show
that the trump plan is in any scenario
other than a biden blowout
donald trump will step up to a podium
and declare victory tomorrow night
and instead here he's saying you know
the real problems
are the crimes committed by barack obama
which of course he still can't actually
enumerate
we've slid into authoritarianism it's
happened slowly over four years
if trump had started with this four
years ago it would have been
wow but just like we've been warning
about normalization it's a little bit
a little bit a little bit and now trump
regularly calls for the
imprisonment of his political enemies of
barack obama joe biden hillary
and it makes news but it is not the
unilateral
outrage the unanimous outrage that it
should be we've all become desensitized
to it to some degree
continuing donald trump then fabricated
a meeting
which he then said was a phone call with
prime minister from japan
shinzo abe the call never happened
people just shrug
it's not even remarkable that trump is
now making up phone calls that didn't
happen
and you will eviscerate your auto
industry
it will be terrible we can't do it you
know we've worked very hard to bring it
back
i met with prime minister abby of japan
great guys since retired he had a
problem with health and uh but a
fantastic man and i said no
shinzo you have to send plants to
michigan you have to send plants to the
united states and he said no no no i
cannot do that that is a private
decision i said shinzo you're a powerful
man i'm sure you can do it
no no no i said you have to do it shinzo
because you're making too many cars
sending them here
we want them made in the united states
you have to do it he says well i can't
the next day they announced there were
five companies
moving to michigan
japan that was japan he was he's a great
guy that one i'll tell you
not only that that phone call never
happened five companies uh
that make cars didn't move into michigan
either it is all made up
saturday night donald trump was in
pennsylvania he again floated this idea
of obama and biden committed crimes
the crowd chants locked them up we still
don't know what are the crimes look at
big tech you look at what's been
happening lately right
you look at the media where they refuse
to cover one of the biggest scandals no
but the biggest scandal is we caught
them spying on our campaign
right we caught them trying to overthrow
a duly elected commonly known as me
president of the united states let's see
what happens
let's see what happens
very dishonest people
you're right well that you're right you
know
there are a lot of people that call that
treason okay that's crazy
let's see what happens the people for
law and order and due process
right uh say lock people up
who haven't even been accused of a crime
trump still struggling with a lot of
words minneapolis continues to
evade him and then portland do we want
to go into portland so badly
take out the anarchists it would take us
about 25 minutes
you saw what happened in minneapolis you
know after a week and a half they could
have called
they could have called a little quicker
like not the only instance you know
maybe just avoid saying minneapolis if
you can't say it one more
and don't forget they've done a terrible
job in minnesota where they let
minneapolis
burn down and then here is donald trump
saying ridiculously that under joe biden
i mentioned this
you won't have heating in the winter
you won't have air conditioning in the
summer biden has vowed to abolish the
entire
u.s oil industry no fracking no mining
no natural gas no heating in the winter
no air conditioning in the summer no
electricity
during peak hours do his followers
believe that
i read an interesting piece over the
weekend catching up on my reading as it
were
that suggests even trump's followers
don't literally believe when trump
says things like there will be no
heating and cooling under joe biden
but they are okay with it because they
just
write it off as this is how politics
works hyperbole
and lies which is problematic because it
normalizes it which is the exact
opposite of what we need it should be
ostracized not normalized
and then just to wrap up the insanity at
an earlier daytime rally in newtown
pennsylvania
donald trump just after we set a record
of 100
000 coronavirus cases in a single
24-hour period
donald trump repeats that we are
rounding the turn
and just doing great on the virus we're
ready we'll have that
and uh and we will have it but even if
you didn't i say
and i say it drives them crazy we're
rounding the turn we're rounding that
turn
we're rounding it
and our economy went down less than any
economy anywhere in the world and it
went up faster by
far you know they keep hearing about
europe europe europe well they're not
doing nearly as well seniors will be
first in line for the vaccine
and the vaccine will be free because
it's not their fault it was china's
fault
china did this to us we have to make
sure
we have to i'm not saying it's going to
happen but
we can make it happen we have to be at
the end of these rallies
trump will do a few rallies today trump
may do a few rallies later this week
while the votes are still being counted
we must make sure that by the end of
this week these rallies are over forever
we don't have a choice it's it's a
desperate
desperate situation we'll have more
clips and coverage
on our instagram page at david pakman
show for a much needed break
from the politics how about coffee
follow me on instagram david.pakman
for my slo-mo espresso shot
from this morning the politics still
matter but just for like a 15-second
break you can find that on my instagram
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
congressman ruben gallego or ruben
gashego as
i would say in argentina is a democratic
congressman representing the 7th
congressional district
in arizona and he joins me today
congressman to start with
we're we're down to the last few days
here in this election
um i i actually agree with donald trump
when he repeats that this is
the most important election he can
remember i happen to agree i think i
disagree
on what the the outcome should be um
different people
putting different weight on polls that
look good for joe biden and polls that
look
not not quite so good what's the right
approach over the last few days here
well the right approach is for us to
just run through the tape that's what
joe biden's telling us
that's what we learned from 2016. we
can't really let up
uh i'm in a sling state here in arizona
florida is also swing state as everybody
knows this thing could come
down to just a couple thousand votes and
if it if not maybe this ends up being a
blow up but that's even a better
scenario so let's hope it to blow up but
in the meantime let's prepare for the
worst uh let's run all the way through
the tape
get everybody every last vote out that
we can uh and you know
there is going to be an attempt for this
president to manipulate the outcome of
the election
especially in the vote counting so the
larger the margin the harder it is for
him to do that
okay so we we know some of the tactics
that donald trump plans to use
including maybe even trying to get a
case
up to his new supreme court justice amy
coney barrett
we know about voter intimidation there's
all these different things that he could
do
joe biden on the other hand expecting
many of these
has lawyers ready but the offense only
needs one plan that the defense hasn't
accounted for so what what are we to do
how can we be prepared for any
eventuality
well i think the most important we could
do is if if you have a ballot just turn
it in
do not wait for it to to go uh in the
mail
because if it comes afterwards you're
gonna try to discount it if you have a
ballot just walk it into the con
recorder right now
there's nothing within any any purview
of the law that they could come up with
that would stop
a ballot that was delivered to your kind
of recorder or the secretary of state's
office whatever it was
before election day uh afterwards
unfortunately they will try to litigate
um you know ballots that came afterwards
even if your state allows it
we can't trust this supreme court uh we
already saw
kavanaugh issued a very loose and flimsy
uh argument for why election day should
be over on election day which has never
happened i don't know what the hell he
thought was going on
uh in the 1800s when we didn't have uh
in 1900s we didn't have instantaneous uh
counting all across the country
uh so but we can't take any chances so
please just return your ballot tell your
friend your families
to go and drop off their ballot uh
instead of putting it in the mail
this is really important because early
when president
trump started to assail the reliability
of the post office
uh many of us said you know the post
office is more than well enough equipped
to handle
all of these ballots even if the volume
were to double triple
you look at the number of holiday cards
that are sent out this is really nothing
and yet you and many others are now
saying
out of an abundance of caution because
we don't know
what legal arguments they might use
you're recommending people use a ballot
drop box rather than
mailing the ballot that's correct and
scared that i even have to do that the
fact that we have to
take all these precautions in the united
states in the year of 2020
as if we're some third world country uh
or some country that is being run by
some kind of like dictatorship
uh it's quite frustrating i shouldn't
have to worry about that
but the whole the whole republican party
is just corrupt
as well as the president as well as his
nominees as the supreme court
if this was just the president acting i
wouldn't be so worried about the fact
that he's corrupted the whole republican
party
and and department justice apparatus we
just can't take any chances
i i was increasingly i was initially
a very hesitant to say too much about
the idea of expanding the court or not
early in the nomination and confirmation
process of amy coney barrett
uh i i've since come around to the idea
that given control of the white house
senate and house of representatives
this is something that democrats should
pursue i don't find the slippery slope
argument credible that if joe biden does
it if he were to win
every president will add seats to the
supreme court you have to have
the house senate and presidency to do it
i think in many situations the general
public wouldn't tolerate it
have you taken a position on the
expansion of the court now that we've
seen the confirmation of amy coney
barrett
in hypocritical fashion i'm open to it
um
obviously you know there's a lot of
devil in the details and and i'd like to
see how they start ruling but
to be honest i'm more leaning towards it
and here's a couple reasons why number
one
the constitution does not disallow it
right of course
you know and if you read the
constitution the whole constitution is
about checks and balances right
where a check on the the house in the
center supposed to be a check on the
executive executives would be
the check on the house and the senate um
but what is
and and the supreme court will see a
check on the executive
legislature so what is the check on the
um
supreme court well there's two options
one impeachment which is a very high
standard to begin with or should be a
high standard
um or you have the power to reconstruct
the
um the supreme court and the circuit
courts
uh and i think that is one of the
options that we have to take right now
because we have an activist court
that is supplanting uh you know
democracy and democratic values
and if that's the case then we have to
use the one uh toolkit available
in our in our toolbox which is either
reducing the court
putting term limits or just adding more
supreme court justices
and if there is you know this tip for
tatwell you know
there shouldn't have been a tip for tap
but the fact is that this has been
politicized in so many ways
first by the rejection of merrick
garland second vibe this rushing of
of amico barrett so we might as well uh
just go full uh full fully into this and
fight it
on a full scale i am um
quite worried about regardless of who
wins but in particular if joe biden wins
i'm worried about what might become a
violent situation um
in different parts of the country i
think that if the president
were to claim that it was rigged that he
really won and in particular if it's
close if it's a blowout for joe biden i
don't think that this is as likely but
if it's close and the president claims
it was rigged
i'm worried about armed violence in the
streets am i wrong to worry about that
i don't think you're wrong to worry
about it but i think at the end of the
day we have to
stick to the one principle which is we
have to preserve democracy
and it's not you know a bunch of
overweight fat guys pretending to be in
the army
um you know are are not going to be able
to stop our democracy from going forward
and so this president can argue whatever
he wants
uh but on january 20th as soon as that
uh
our president vice president biden is
inaugurated he needs to be out of that
white house and he could
talk his run his mouth all he wants uh
but he will be out of that white house
by volition or uh by force
uh and we have to all think about it
that way so let's not fear
you know uh these these so-called
militias i mean they're about
you know 30 to 40 big macs away all from
having heart attacks anyway
uh we need to just focus uh on winning
this election
and then by january uh 20th on
inauguration day
if he's not out of there uh out of the
white house and he's not claiming to be
he needs to stop claiming to be
president
we follow him with treason charges and
we file anybody else that's supporting
him
uh on coronavirus um by if joe biden
wins by the time he
takes office we will be either in the
middle of or even beyond
spike number three whether you call it a
wave or not it's certainly
we're experiencing the third spike right
now a lot of the things that should have
been done early
don't make any sense once we're a year
in so in other words
uh you know once it's completely
widespread the importance of contact
tracing goes
down we will be well into the
development of the vaccine etc
what exactly do you want joe biden to do
differently
as of january when it comes to the virus
well i think he's going to have to lead
by example that's going to be very
helpful to begin with number two
helping implement a nationwide mask
mandate
uh number three contract tracing will be
difficult but testing is still very
important
and making sure that we have testing
that is nationwide uh
and quick uh and then lastly of course
having
um a you know sufficient amount of ppe
for our
uh our hospitals our nurses and our
first responders
because they're going to end up being
doing a lot of this this grunt work
have you as a member of congress gotten
any
timelines that we may not have gotten as
the public with regard to
vaccination and distribution no we
haven't gotten any information
that you that the public is not privy to
and what
do you have an expectation now about
what 2021 will look like
you know even if we get a uh a safe
vaccine i don't foresee us being able to
to spread it uh and and implement it
fast and far enough for us to have what
i would call a quote normal normal
uh 2021 i think we're going to see 2021
uh first of all if there's a vaccine
it's going to go to first responder it's
going to go to teachers it's going to go
to our
our seniors that are the most vulnerable
um and then
you know after that i think they'll
start moving along
lines but i think 2020 we should repair
ourselves by
again more social continuous social
distancing
uh putting on a mass mandate uh and uh
and then you know wait for that vaccine
to hit a congressman i so appreciate
your time today thank you so much
thank you the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so intuitively anyone with common sense
knows that rallies with thousands of
people crowded together mostly without
masks
aren't a good idea during a global
hundred-year pandemic most people
understand that and especially as we get
into spike number three of the virus in
the united states
um you would be extra uh
aware of the fact that that's a bad idea
but donald trump has continued to do the
rallies and we now have a new analysis
from stanford university which found
that looking at 18 trump rallies
specific there's way more than 18 but
looking at just 18
those 18 rallies and you can get the
exact list in looking at the study
were responsible for roughly 30 000
cases of coronavirus
and 700 deaths the study is called the
effects of large group meetings on the
spread of covet 19
the case of trump rallies now what is
really important to understand
is well two things number one this only
looked at 18 rallies so
the total number is of course much
higher but the other
element of this is that when they say
these 18 rallies led to 700 deaths
the important caveat is not necessarily
among rally attendees in other words
it's not just about you if you want to
take the risk of going
and you were the only person at risk
that would be one
thing as vox notes a rally goer
may become infected with a mild case but
the same rally-goer
gives the virus to their wife or their
parent who gives it to a co-worker to
sister
and then to grandma who dies of
coronavirus
the deaths also are people who are
getting the virus
despite not having been at the rallies
if it were as simple as
700 of the people who went to the
rallies died
okay it's tragic but at least it's
people choosing to be
there who are dying this is people in
the community because
it's a virus and that's how it spreads
and you might think by the way
that killing your own supporters is a
bad idea and you'd be right
but again presumably some of the people
dying as a result of the rallies aren't
even trump's supporters
uh although people do tend to live in
ideologically similar groups as a
general rule
up and and the reality is the election's
not going to come down to 700 people and
meanwhile
trump ridicules joe biden for wearing a
mask
and having safe drive-in rallies where
people sit in their cars it's not just
incompetence
it's immorality and it's a complete
disregard for human life
often when we say disregard for human
life it's a metaphor
it's hyperbolic it's an exaggeration
this time it's not it's it's just
literal disregard for human life 700
people died as a result of 18 trump
rallies
and trump is holding five more rallies
today
it's extremely difficult for me to even
understand how donald trump is even
competitive in this election like i i
understand
specifically he lies and people fall for
it
and he played on racial animus from the
obama era you know all this stuff
together people
fear of losing status all of this but in
terms of how frightening it is for our
country
how badly it bodes for the future of the
united states
even just looking at this rally example
i mean they ca they claim to be pro-life
trump claims to be the most pro-life
president ever
but standing around to see trump is
worth passing along the virus and
killing people
how pro-life is that not very and
unfortunately i i we're at the end of
the game
right unfortunately there's
a reasonable chance that we have four
more years of this
and if that's the case we will have much
to discuss and figure out either way
we'll have much to discuss and figure
out including
what happens to 60 million trumpists if
biden wins
but they still live in the country we'll
talk about all of that
donald trump jr appeared on the ingram
angle
on fox news on thursday night
where he made the absurd ridiculous
immoral disgusting claim that
coronavirus deaths are almost
nothing a thousand people
died in the united states of coronavirus
on that day and he is on fox news
saying these idiot liberals won't tell
you
that deaths are almost nothing and by
the way
if you want to learn more about his data
you can check his instagram
i'm not kidding take a look at this
these people
these people are truly morons you know
what i mean and i like how they go after
scott atlas because he's not an
epidemiologist but sanjay gupta now
magically is
i mean give me a break laura the reality
is this if you look i put it up on my
instagram a couple days ago because i
went through the cdc data because i kept
hearing about new infections
but i was like well why aren't they
talking about this oh oh because the
number is almost nothing
because we've gotten control of this
thing we understand how to how it works
they have the therapeutics to be able to
deal with this if you look at that look
at my instagram it's gone to
almost nothing right right donald trump
jr's instagram is the top place
for health news don is analyzing health
data
on his instagram page if you want to
follow him there
the deaths are almost nothing we've had
more than 700 deaths
per the stanford study just because of
18 of donald trump's rallies
we had a thousand dead on the day don jr
said deaths are almost nothing we had
another 900 dead the day after don jr
said deaths are almost nothing there
were another thousand dead the day
before don jr said deaths are almost
nothing
and another thousand the day before that
these
people aside from being liars and
debasing
truth they've debased the value of human
life
when a thousand people per day are dying
and
they say we did it we're rounding the
turn
we're doing great deaths are almost
nothing
you're actually devaluing human life
they claim to be pro-life people
they say the reason the reason we're
against abortion
is we value human life above everything
else
well apparently they don't value human
life
above stock market having a grocery
store
uh allowing full capacity rather than
partial
schools etc etc these are the
understand the backwards nature of what
we're seeing
if you ask people what is most important
to you
a lot of these folks say life human life
is sacred even at the zygotic stage
and then a thousand people die and then
another thousand and then another
thousand and they say deaths are almost
nothing
uh in reality reelection is the most
valuable thing to them way more valuable
than life
and the stock market yes for sure and by
the way
you know don i i guess this is a good
moment to insert some
facts about therapeutics um don says you
know our therapeutics are just
absolutely fantastic i would speak over
the weekend i uh spoke to an er doctor
friend of mine
and during the big spike we had in
massachusetts
remember their place we're in our third
spike in the u.s but there are places
that were able to avoid a second spike
massachusetts was one of them during the
initial spike in massachusetts this
friend
was moved from the er to a covet floor
and he might have to go back there
in a few weeks due to the spike that is
now being experienced
he said we really don't have good
therapeutics at this point it's actually
remarkable how we still don't have good
therapeutics
hydroxychloroquine was obviously a bust
fox news pretends like they never even
mentioned it anymore
remdessevere more recently it doesn't
really seem to have
even the modest functioning that we
thought it did from early studies
the dexamethasone does seem to help some
patients and that's good
that's really a general thing anytime
you have inflammation
doctors would guess if you give a
steroid you can reduce inflammation
ideally to put the body in a better
state to fight
off the virus and heal itself it's not
anything particular about this virus
that's a general medical principle
and so what this doctor was telling me
is we really don't have
particularly good functioning
therapeutics at this point now
thankfully because we managed for a
period of time
to reduce hospitalizations so that the
hospitals were less full that's
reversing but for a while hospitals were
less full
we have better protocols in terms of ers
being able to recognize the stage of
disease
who needs the dex who needs a ventilator
who needs oxygen
thanks to that and the hospitals being
less full
we've reduced the mortality rate it also
does seem like when you're spending more
time
outdoors than indoors when you do catch
it you're ideally catching it with a
lower viral load
which seems to correlate with a less
serious case okay all of that stuff
but the therapeutics we really aren't
doing great on even the monoclonal
antibody data is not great from what
we've seen so far
so don jr is wrong about everything he's
wrong morally he's wrong factually
he's wrong statistically and of course
he's wrong in that they value life above
all
else just look at the way that they've
been behaving we have a voicemail number
that number is 219 to david p
um this is a very interesting voicemail
this voicemail
raises an interesting question i had not
thought about
let's take a listen to it hi david
uh i was just wondering um if
biden takes the if biden is elected what
is the likelihood
that uh clarence thomas resigned
in the lame duck session thanks
okay that's a very very interesting
question
if indeed joe biden defeats donald trump
um would clarence thomas
maybe immediately retire from the
supreme court
allowing trump to push through
a supreme court pick younger than thomas
who will be on the court for longer
i don't think it's particularly likely
because clarence thomas is relatively
young he's 72 and
i don't know that clarence thomas has
any interest in leaving the court
so it's not something i would expect but
i wonder
i do wonder if joe biden does win
will there be people on the right
putting pressure on clarence thomas or
putting pressure on trump
to call up clarence thomas to say listen
let's put in a 45 year old
and establish ingrain absent an
expansion of the court
a conservative supreme court for a
really really long time
it's a scary thought and i wish i could
say they could never do it
they during a lame duck they could never
do it because they said in 2016 you
don't do it during the last year
guys they just did it during the last
week with amy coney barrett so i think
they would be able to do it
i don't know that clarence thomas
is seen as an urgent person to replace
with someone younger he's 72
ruth bader ginsburg was far older
and although i believe antonin scalia
was only 74 when he
suddenly died uh i i don't expect that
to happen but it's a very intere
you're thinking about this the right way
which is no matter what
what last middle finger fuse is trump
going to be able to throw
whenever it is that he's finally done
whether it's now
or whether it's four years from now okay
tomorrow night
i will be live streaming election
results we are going to have
all the coverage for you we will be
looking at network
calls we will be doing our own map we
will have a likely and projected map
producer pat put together a fantastic
chart of bellwether counties counties
that
with almost no exceptions the winner of
those counties
almost always wins the states excellent
data we have all of it
okay and i will be starting with the
first results just
short of 7 p.m eastern time tomorrow
evening
just short just shy of 4 p.m eastern
pacific
i will be on youtube twitch and facebook
go to youtube now and click the set
reminder button on our youtube stream
the more people that click that button
the more
interest you are signaling to youtube's
algorithm about
our coverage and thus the more people
that will be suggested our coverage by
youtube
very exciting stuff on today's bonus
show
donald trump changed his election night
plan he had a party planned at his hotel
instead he's going to be at the white
house we will talk about it on the bonus
show
texas republicans tried to stop drive
through voting and try to get a hundred
and some odd thousand votes thrown out
they have failed to do it that's good
but they're continuing to fight
that's not good and we are now realizing
that about 100 million people are going
to be voting early
last election only about 135 million
people voted total
100 million people will have voted
already
before election day incredible we will
talk about
what those numbers look like in terms of
where they're coming from and whether we
can read anything into them about the
future of this election
my argument is even if you can let's not
let's just get out and vote
all of those stories on today's bonus
show
two ways to access the bonus show become
a member
at joinpackman.com or become a patron
at patreon.com davidpakmanshow i will
see you then
and then tomorrow and then on our live
election night coverage see you then
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video